Schock bei der weltklimakonferenz in bonn 2017 sind die co2 emissionen wieder angestiegen wie gerufen kommen also projekte die das
klimaschädliche kohlendioxid
Nachträglich aus der luft filtern jetzt ist eine kommerzielle anlage dieser art in betrieb genommen worden und zwar in ins land und sie macht aus
Co2 stein wie diese technologie tatsächlich funktioniert ob sie sich lohnt und ob sie sogar die klimakrise lösen kann jetzt den klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
Die idee ist großartig und dabei nicht einmal besonders kompliziert das
Klimaschädliche co2 wird aus der luft gefiltert und in den untergrund geleitet das glas reagiert dort mit einem
Basaltgestein dass beispielsweise eisen und kalzium enthält das ergebnis dass co2 mineralisiert, zu karbonat. Also zu festem gestein
Diese versteinerung funktioniert tatsächlich und jetzt wird sie zum ersten mal mit der sogenannten direct er capture technologie
kombiniert das schweizer unternehmen klein works will beweisen dass sich aircap gelohnt denn bislang galt diese
Innovative idee als wenig effektiv und aufwendig und so hat die firma eine ihrer anlagen nach island gebracht
Wo sie jetzt fleißig co2 schlucken soll und zwar in zusammenarbeit mit dem isländischen
geothermiekraftwerk handy auch hier wird das treibhausgas
also
Im wasser gelöst und in den untergrund gepumpt 400 bis 800 meter tief dort ist der boden von hydrothermalen
Quellen durchzogen zwei jahre dauert es dann etwa bis durch die chemische reaktion das co2 in karbonat
umgewandelt wird das wirklich großartiger daran durch diesen schritt ist das dann
mineralisierte co2 tatsächlich aus dem verkehr gezogen und für das klima keineswegs mehr schädlich pro tag sollen somit mit dieser pilotanlage
135 kilogramm co2 entsorgt werden die projektleiterin elisabeth
Er vom reykjavik energy sagt mit der integration der kleine words technologie haben wir nun eine lösung die unabhängig von
Emissionsquellen überall dort einsetzbar ist wo es bei salzgestein gibt das sind in diesen zeiten tatsächlich wie ein ziemlich großer hoffnungsschimmer
Denn, grob gesagt ist basalt erkaltete lava und somit fast überall auf der erde zu finden auf dem meeresgrund besteht
zu großen teilen auf basalt das beteiligte forschungsteam schätzt dass sich allein in island 400
gigatonnen co2 im basaltgestein lagern lassen und das ist etwa zehnmal so viel vom
klimagas dass wir menschen derzeit pro jahr in die atmosphäre schleudern die verantwortlichen haben also allen grund
Optimistisch zu sein so wie der ceo von rheinbergs christoph gewalt das potenzial zur skalierung unserer technologie in kombination
Mit co2 speicherung ist gewaltig und das nicht nur hier in island sondern in vielen anderen regionen mit ähnlichen
gesteinsformationen noch realistisch gesehen ist längst nicht jeder standort für diese technologie geeignet der große nachteil es wird sehr viel flüssigkeit
gebraucht pro tonne co2 etwa 25 kubikmeter die technologie funktioniert, zudem nur mit einer wärmequelle
Um das co2 überhaupt erst aus dem filter
Zu lösen doch die forschung an solchen technologien ist dennoch enorm wichtig für die klimaziele und wir haben hier ja schon öfter darüber
berichtet der herkömmliche klimaschutz scheinen schon lange nicht mehr auszureichen um unsere erde vor einem klimakollaps
kollaps zu bewahren das bestätigen auch die neuesten zahlen passen zur weltklimakonferenz in bonn kommt ein forschungsteam das
global carbon project zu einem fairen ergebnis nach drei jahren stagnation werden die globalen co2 emissionen
Im jahr 2017 wieder ansteigen warum also nicht auf solche techniken des geo-engineering
zurückgreifen vor allem wenn die basis dafür stimmt denn ja potenzial ist da denn wie gesagt wenn der klimakiller kohlendioxid
Dauerhaft in großen mengen aus der luft entfernt werden würde könnte man. Den co2 gehalt der atmosphäre
Tatsächlich wieder auf den ursprünglichen wert reduzieren unter diesen umständen sollte man auch darüber hinwegsehen dass die finanzierung
Im moment noch kaum zu stemmen ist davon fahren ist unfassbar teuer pro tonne kostet die co2 abscheidung derzeit mehrere hundert euro
das zeigen erfahrungswerte der schweizer
Anlagen das unternehmen selbst rechnet damit dass der preis demnächst auf etwa 100 euro
Sinkt dort selbst das ist vergleichsweise teuer der plan der firma ist es das gespeicherte
kohlendioxid zu verkaufen und zwar an regierungen organisationen und einzelpersonen die sich damit klimaneutralität
Erkaufen können wenn ihr kein video zu diesem thema und auch
Zu allen themen verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Auf die glocke nur dann verpasst er kein video hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
2016 stellt neuen klima negativ rekord auf ja auf 2016 war kein gutes jahr für den klimawandel
ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran